there are growing demands for Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
to recuse himself from Donald Trump's at
some point upcoming Senate impeachment
trial what I really get a kick out of
here is that there are so many corrupt
Trump brown nosers in positions of power
in which for whom recusal is constantly
coming up let's go through some of them
remember Donald Trump's beleaguered
attorney general Jeff Sessions he said
years ago it feels like a decade ago
years ago Jeff Sessions had contacts
with Russia not me not the campaign no
no no definitely not us turns out Jeff
Sessions was lying and he ended up
recusing himself from all Russia related
matters we then had Donald Trump's and
still have Donald Trump's propagandizing
Attorney General William Bar William bar
immediately did Trump's bidding after
becoming AG writing and disseminating
that completely bogus four-page
propaganda letter claiming that the
Moller report shows Trump did nothing
wrong
that letter became the basis for Trump's
national vindication tour Trump's
cronies Trump's family Trump himself
going all around the country using that
propaganda letter from bar to say oh
yeah we are completely vindicated and
numerous legal experts calling for
William bars recusal when it comes to
the Ukraine fiasco other investigative
and criminal matters relating to Donald
Trump and then now we have Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell who as I
told you last week has been so effective
at pushing through hundreds of wacky and
often unqualified right-wing judges many
into lifetime positions of power and now
Mitch McConnell has said he would not be
an impartial juror in Donald Trump's
impeachment Moskow Mitch said he would
be in quote total coordination with the
Trump White House about how the Senate
will run Donald from some Pietschmann
trial this is like letting the defendant
coordinate with the jury in a criminal
trial and Mitch McConnell admitted this
in public Mitch McConnell also said in
public he is not an impartial juror in
this game Democratic senator sherrod
Brown says there is more and more talk
in Washington DC that Mitch McConnell
should recuse himself from the trial now
I really want everybody to understand
this this is this is a really important
thing because they are playing major
games with the terms political and the
term partisan Mitch McConnell keeps
saying listen it lately he keeps saying
this is important lately Mitch McConnell
keeps saying impeachment is a political
process I expect that this will come
down along partisan lines Republicans
voting to acquit and Democrats voting to
convict now there are a few things here
first of all it's hilarious that for
weeks leading up to Donald Trump's
impeachment the entire time that we had
hearings impeachment hearings in the
house Intel committee and in the House
Judiciary Committee Republicans were
insisting there's no crime Trump was
insisting there is no crime how can you
impeach without a crime and we kept
explaining to them guys impeachment is a
political process it does not require a
crime they keep saying no crime no crime
now Trump is impeached and in defending
a total farce of a trial that they want
in the Senate they have switched their
talking point now they are saying hey
guys this is a political process this is
not a criminal process we're going to
run the trial as a political process not
as a criminal process because it's not a
criminal one they revel in their own
hypocrisy so pointing this out to them
is moot or at least pointless but I want
to point it out to you so let's clarify
let's just go to what the Constitution
and the rule of law say whether a
president is worthy of impeachment does
not depend on whether they committed a
crime period that's just that's it the
Constitution outlines that crimes are
not required for impeachment to be the
correct action for the house to take
very good number two the Constitution
says that senators voting in an
impeachment trial must remain impartial
now who enforces that impartiality
that's where we get into a problem it's
supposed to be the the Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell working in
concert with the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court who oversees the trial in
the Senate in this case that's
right-wing justice
john roberts now it's really important
to understand that the odds that Mitch
McConnell actually refuses himself are
almost zero is it's not literally zero
but it's almost zero and it's all
Republicans that are to blame for that
it would only take a few Republicans to
join Democrats and independents in the
Senate of which there are 47 in total to
say Mitch McConnell cannot be majority
leader or Mitch McConnell cannot manage
this trial or Mitch McConnell must
recused himself and they would have a
majority immediately so as bad of an
actor as Mitch McConnell is we have to
hold the Republican Party accountable
because it is all of the other
Republicans I guess we would say the
fifty-two Republicans other than Mitch
McConnell who continue to prop them up
and I get why they're propping him up as
I said last week and I've been saying
for a while Mitch McConnell has been an
extremely effective political operative
for the Republican Party and for the
reactionary right-wing movement for a
very long time now and they don't have
an interest in limiting his power
because they're thrilled with what Mitch
McConnell has done it's disgusting it's
sad the hypocrisy knows no bounds but
what we come back to again is that we
can remove Mitch McConnell he has a
challenger in Kentucky Amy McGrath we
can remove Donald Trump we talk about
legislative solutions congressional
solutions there is one solution that is
rapidly approaching only a ten and a
half months away at this point barely
ten months actually and it is just
voting these people out we can do it and
it may be the only way to get them out
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show and follow me while you're on your
Instagram app at david dot Pakman tech
in with me this week for pictures from
my trip during David Pakman show
vacation today's program brought to you
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman
Blink astiz a great service that I use
all the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into 15
minute
audiobooks that you can listen to and
you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I listen
to on bling cos they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa k ma n